seine kollegin paulina sascha
wir wollten euch einfach mal fragen ich
habe mich daran erinnert dass wir uns ja
so vor drei jahren ungefähr in münchen
getroffen haben auf ein bierchen oder
milch getrunken und damals war alles am
anfang und jetzt hat sich so unglaublich
viel getan in den letzten jahren und ich
wollte einfach mal fragen hätten ihr
hättet ihr das erwartet hätte ich auch
gesagt dass sie irgendwann mal bei
christoph landet bei klick zu ihr wollte
er nicht und jetzt seid ihr da warum ja
danke für die frage erst mal ich weiß
nicht was genau welche veränderungen
welche lage gemeint auf youtube
allgemein schon klar ja gedacht dass
youtube groß wird schon weil man man man
hat das ja gesehen man hat gesehen wie
die amerikanischen youtuber zum beispiel
sich weiterentwickeln für den kanal
gemacht haben hatten wir in den ersten
wochen sollen 20 30 abonnenten und dann
kamen so eine youtube co promotion dazu
wo wir auf der startseite gefüttert
wurden und dann waren es plötzlich 5000
dann 15.000 dass das haben wir schon
extrem gefeiert 15.000 abonnenten was
geht ab und dann hat sich das einfach so
weiter entwickeln ehrlich gesagt ja
wir haben uns nicht gedacht dass
irgendwann fast eine ganze million
abonnenten haben werden weil es schon
eine große zahl ist aber darum ging es
uns auch nie glauben nicht neu so
wussten wir irgendwie schon wer sich wie
entwickeln wir wussten auf jeden fall
das war auch sehr viele abonnenten haben
werden weil die jungs nicht mehr gegeben
haben wir haben es ja auch damals nicht
umsonst vorgestellt bei uns und sogar
zweimal und wir wussten auch dass
gronkjaer richtig große nummer sein wird
weigerung einfach toll ist mit seiner
stimme und sein letzter als ich ich
schaue auch gern dazu wir wussten auch
da ist zum beispiel auch einen unserer
lieblings youtuber und das kriegst du
auch so weit kommen wird wussten ja auch
weil auch eigentlich ziemlich gute
arbeit leistet ich glaube youtube hat
noch eine große zukunft als wird noch
einiges passieren glaube ich hatte
gerade unten in tostedt wo er ist krank
was machen diese zwei spaß nicht hier
wo ist gott und genau genauso ein paar
monaten vielleicht jahre man weiß nie
aber klicks und bekommt alle natürlich
auch gedacht und gewusst dass irgendwann
ein interview mit christoph machen also
wir haben das ja auch versprochen damals
warum
hat sich so ergeben unser buch ist
eigentlich sollte eigentlich zum thema
des interviews teilen noch mal zeigen
wir haben uns gedacht jetzt gerade passt
weil das buch herausgebracht haben
vielleicht gibt es menschen da draußen
die klicks um kennen und uns nicht